[Music]
in 2009
two researchers ran a simple experiment
they took
everything we know about our solar
system and calculated where
every planet would be up to 5 billion
years in the future
to do so they ran over 2 000 numerical
simulations
with the same exact initial conditions
except for one difference
the distance between mercury and the sun
modified by less than a millimeter from
one simulation to the next
shockingly in about one percent of their
simulations
mercury's orbit changed so drastically
that it could plunge into the sun or
collide with venus
worse yet in one simulation it
destabilized
the entire inner solar system this was
no error
the astonishing variety in results
reveals the truth
that our solar system may be much less
stable
than it seems astrophysicists refer to
this astonishing property of
gravitational systems
as the n-body problem while we have
equations that can completely predict
the motions of two gravitating masses
our analytical tools fall short when
faced with more populated systems
it's actually impossible to write down
all the terms
of a general formula that can exactly
describe the motion
of three or more gravitating objects
why the issue lies in how many
unknown variables an n-body system
contains
thanks to isaac newton we can write a
set of equations
to describe the gravitational force
acting between
bodies however when trying to find a
general solution
for the unknown variables in these
equations we're faced with a
mathematical constraint
for each unknown there must be at least
one equation
that independently describes it
initially
a two-body system appears to have more
unknown
variables for position and velocity than
equations of motion
however there's a trick consider the
relative
position and velocity of the two bodies
with respect
to the center of gravity of the system
this reduces the number of unknowns
and leaves us with a solvable system
with three or more
orbiting objects in the picture
everything gets messier
even with the same mathematical trick of
considering
relative motions we're left with more
unknowns
than equations describing them there are
simply too many variables
for this system of equations to be
untangled into a general solution
but what does it actually look like for
objects in our universe to move
according to analytically unsolvable
equations of motion
a system of three stars like alpha
centauri
could come crashing into one another or
more likely
some might get flung out of orbit after
a long time of apparent stability
other than a few highly improbable
stable configurations
almost every possible case is
unpredictable
on long time scales each has an
astronomically large range of potential
outcomes
dependent on the tiniest of differences
in position
and velocity this behavior is known as
chaotic by physicists
and is an important characteristic of
n-body systems
such a system is still deterministic
meaning there's nothing random about it
if multiple systems start from the exact
same conditions
they'll always reach the same result but
give
one a little shove at the start and all
bets are off that's clearly relevant for
human space missions when complicated
orbits
need to be calculated with great
precision
thankfully continuous advancements in
computer simulations
offer a number of ways to avoid
catastrophe
by approximating the solutions with
increasingly powerful processors
we can more confidently predict the
motion of n-body systems
on long time scales and if one body in a
group of three
is so light it exerts no significant
force on the other two
the system behaves with very good
approximation
as a two-body system this approach is
known as the restricted
three-body problem it proves extremely
useful
in describing for example an asteroid in
the earth's sun
gravitational field or a small planet
in the field of a black hole and a star
as for our solar system you'll be happy
to hear that we can have reasonable
confidence in its stability
for at least the next several hundred
million years
though if another star launched from
across the galaxy
is on its way to us all bets are off
intrigued by these mysterious
possibilities we highly recommend the
hugo award-winning science fiction
epic the three body problem this
gripping adventure will take you past
the limits of your imagination
and perhaps the universe download a free
audiobook version
from audible.com ted dash ed
and don't say we didn't warn you